i'm like kind of freaked out still like
i'm still kind of like oh i don't know
like i was so anxious for him to come
and now all of a sudden i'm like oh this
is going too fast a little scared
next lindsay has a baby what are the
pregnancy cravings
i would always crave a blue slurpee i'm
a gas station in a slim gym
welcome welcome welcome to dancing with
the stars watching dancing with the
stars from home
are you judgy are you like
planning your net are yes okay
very hey youtube beautiful women
oh my god that it was the sweetest thing
i
almost i was tearing up
okay bumping bumping girls here in utah
yeah who would have ever thought from
the ballroom to your living room lindsay
i know i just can't believe it whitney
and i are sitting here both pregnant
chatting yeah we were tonight we were
just comparing our bellies like can you
believe that
we both have bellies right now it's
really weird well the good news is is
that i'm fully prepared i know that
you're due
like any moment and so do we need a code
word here like if something happens
so if it looks like i peed my pants i
might have actually peed my pants okay
if not
then we'll just go ahead and just get up
and go okay it'll be great we'll capture
it on camera you're packed you got the
bag ready yeah my bag's in my room we're
good to go just call my husband
and say meet me at the hospital i love
this we've missed seeing you and we
missed you on dancing stars this season
[Music]
what has it been like to be sort of at
home and nesting
and while watching it's kind of been
crazy actually i think for
me just watching it i feel so proud of
all of my friends like because they are
doing
so incredible and a little part of me
definitely misses it but this is such a
special journey
for both of us and i don't know how
lindsay feels but i just feel like
just so grateful and i'm just so content
with like
where i am right now in my life so yeah
i completely agree it's so much fun
watching and being able to be like on
the other side
because we can just be a fan you know we
can liter i genuinely feel like a fan i
get heated at the judge's comments
it felt like at moments you gave up like
there was moments and i felt like your
spirit dropped
and then but listen i don't want to
discourage you because i do think you
are a fantastic dancer it's just so
funny how i'm watching as if i'm like
a fan on a show that i would normally be
a part of no it was really weird i was
going through some of my dances though
on youtube like
i can't remember last week and it kind
of made me a little bit sad
because you're like oh i kind of miss
dancing i miss it so much but
anyway we just we're happy with where we
are so did you plan this
no yeah we actually
um you know we got our husbands we're
like okay this is how
you guys this is um a meeting that we're
having about babies yes
i know it's just it's actually insane
we've done so many things in our lives
together so it's like
naturally why wouldn't we get pregnant
together but it's so funny because you
can't really
plan pregnancy like i mean you can you
can plan when you want to try
but it's not like it's always going to
happen when you want it too so it's
pretty crazy that it happened for us
yep both when we wanted it to know and
you're due in january and how are you
feeling
i'm starting to get a little bit
uncomfortable like the second trimester
was amazing
i just hit my third trimester last week
so i'm starting to get a little
uncomfortable starting to do like this
kind of stuff
like out of my bed but i feel good like
i still feel like i have energy i'm not
quite ready to have this baby yet have
you guys had a conversation with
each other about you know we'll bring
the babies over you'll take them we'll
have play dates like
how are you like this is going to be
full throttle all together oh yeah it'll
be full throttle for sure we're going to
take turns day care like you once a week
yes and it's perfect because we have a
boy like a boy and a girl so i feel like
it'll be good because i feel like
boy and girl like friendship
relationships are so much fun i had
so many close guy friends growing up and
so i'm like pumped for
my little girl to have a we'll sneak in
some dance lessons in there yeah
maybe partners maybe boyfriend
girlfriend we know no will they be going
to ballroom dance class together
i mean i think do we have the next pro
couple
that's the only fitting i'm like i feel
like it's gotta happen
yeah even if we just enter them into
like a little tiny competition when
they're young
we just have to just for fun yeah like
just even if they don't love it just
do it just because that's one thing this
is your first child for both of you
which is so special
when you think about meeting your little
person
and looking at them for the first time
you know
what do you think about that's like the
craziest part for me still because i
mean i can like
full on i'm sure you can too like i can
full on field body parts inside of my
stomach i'm like there's her head
there's her hand i feel her foot kicking
it's just so bizarre to me that there is
a human
in here that very soon is going to be
like in my arms and it's just
it blows my mind it makes me so excited
and i'm just like
i mean i am so ready for that i'm like
okay i'm ready for you little one
let's do this thing i know there's a lot
that i'm not like
that i'm gonna have to figure out and i
think that will just happen naturally i
hope
but it is really it's just a
mind-blowing thing
it's still not real to me like i i still
feel him in there all the time but it's
still not real that i'll actually like
have him
and hold him it's just going to be
really really weird i don't think i'm
quite ready like you are
well yeah i'm like you'll get there when
there's no space anymore and you're like
get your head out of my rib cage
she'll be like hopefully it'll be feet
first i'm like kind of freaked out still
like i'm still kind of like oh i don't
know like i was so anxious for him to
come
and now all of a sudden i'm like oh this
is going too fast i only have 10 weeks
left this is
going way too fast it's crazy a little
scared i definitely feel like i lucked
out with lindsay she's the
best partner four and one nice that's
it what do you think will be harder
motherhood or training these celebrities
how to dance oh gosh
i will say we definitely got some good
practice in with some of our partners we
definitely like it sometimes our job is
babysitting yeah and we'll be great at
that
yep exactly and the good thing is we'll
love our babies i mean i've
loved all my partners but not like a
motherly love sometimes so it'll be much
easier to handle
yes for sure have you been dancing have
you been working out i definitely have
not been dancing
yeah i know but i feel like i tried to
and i'm like oh this is not like good
body will not but
i mean i've been trying to work out and
lately i've literally just gone on walks
and that's literally
the best i can do at this point no
that's good i
definitely worked out as much as i could
up until about
yeah you were really good when i hit
like 35 weeks i stopped but i actually
am a crazy person and started filming a
workout program
during my pregnancy which i will be
launching like within the next month and
a half
but i mean you wake up in the morning
you're like i don't really want to do
anything yeah
and you're like i'm growing a human that
should be enough but it did feel good to
still like get in some sort of
physical activity just to help with like
stress i mean it wasn't to help me lose
weight because
that's not happening right now we're
naturally going to just gain weight but
it was fun to kind of
stay in touch with that what are the
pregnancy cravings like what's your late
night i have to have it
babe run to the store um in the second
trimester i
would always crave a blue slurpee at the
gas station in a slim gym
oh and my husband was like uh i have
never seen you walk out of the gas
station with a slim jim and a slurpee
i'm like
this is just how i feel and i need it i
literally needed it like every week it
was
really really weird that is so funny
i have not i'm like waiting and i mean
i'm days away i'm still
waiting for that like pregnancy hormone
i'm afraid it's you craving like i don't
know what it is but
i haven't had but i'm also a very like
wide range eater like i eat
everything and anything so i don't even
know if you could fit a weird craving
into my diet because i'm probably
already eating it
anything that you're grossed out about
though
or no i will say i'm not eating as much
red meat but not because i'm like
grossed out by it but i crave like
carbs way more how are the husbands are
they
pow-wowing as well like are they they
actually haven't probably
really happened no i think the last time
they chatted was when we had just found
out you were
pregnant i know they need to get
together again because carson
has a mini panic attack every time we
talk about the birth like the birth
itself
the birth why the birth like and i'm
actually calm about it like i'm like
okay i feel like i'm
okay like i'm kind of prepared like i
just want to get this baby out
yeah and we can't even talk about it
without him just freaking out so
i think he needs to talk to zam i don't
know what sam is feeling but
sam i mean i think it's gonna be more
after that they're going to need to pow
out
because he's actually been handling this
very well he's handled me and my
craziness
yeah very great we've been together for
a long time so he's seen a lot of the
things
but he's handling it really well which
is good and i
i mean luckily i'm glad because i think
i'm a little bit more anxious about the
actual birth like that kind of scares me
and so he i think knows he has to be
very calm about it so i think we're just
opposite
we are completely opposite well all of
his sisters have had really traumatic
births like and they've had traumatic
bursts like
in the last like two years so and he's
never seen a birth so he's just like
i just i'm expecting the worst so here
we go you know but you know what it's
gonna be
you're okay honey i know you're awesome
okay that's literally what it's gonna be
what has been the most
unexpected part of both of your
pregnancies oh my goodness
i think the biggest thing for me was i
actually i mean i still do love being
pregnant but i just like
i think i was expecting to be a little
bit more like disappointed and just like
frustrated with like the body changes
but from the beginning it was like the
thing i looked forward to the most
i was like pumped to get a actual bump
and be able to be like yes
rock the bump so that kind of surprised
me i think that's gonna be hard though
as dancers i mean your
your bodies have been scrutinized and
judged for your whole lives
it is really hard especially when you
get on the scale you're like oh my gosh
i've
never been this heavy but you gotta
realize obviously we have
we're growing up a human which is
amazing but it is really weird to see
that and
it's true our bodies have been
scrutinized for forever so it is really
weird but it's such a magical thing
you don't really think about that and
like lindsay said like i look forward to
it like anytime somebody's like
you look so big i take that as a
compliment like i'm like thank you
that's good
you're like what the hell's happening
yes i love it do you feel that hollywood
pressure of like
how she got her body back oh gosh
honestly
that is the most scared for me i am so
scared about that i
like don't know how i'm going to feel
about it i feel like it's so scary
it's just like we're we need you in a
costume it's been four days
where's the i need you in a naked
dancing with the stars i've had a lot of
friends who just have had babies too and
cousins and stuff and they just like
they just look wrecked i mean absolutely
correct
it's not gonna be real it's hard but i
think like
i don't know it's hard because we
obviously don't know like what our
bodies are gonna do
so i guess i'm like i've been preparing
myself for that for the past couple
weeks because i think
i'm naturally gonna be like conscious
about it but i'm trying to just remember
like
it's gonna happen at its own pace and a
lot of moms tell me that honestly like
yeah your body gets a little bit wrecked
and you might need a lot of pain but
like when you see your little baby you
don't care at all and i
i do feel like that will be very helpful
i think to dance though
it is going to be different like i think
to actually
get on the show get in a costume and
dance we won't be the same
i don't think well i don't know i mean
peter freaking rocked it
and i thought she looked more beautiful
after like her first season back after
her baby i'm like you've never like she
looked so incredible so it's like
we just you know we just do it i'm just
gonna dream through that oh
really we're not really ours look really
good on the stomach area yeah
like we can cover we cover some stuff
right yeah
you just put that nude with the
rhinestones yeah exactly
so gender reveal parties people love
them people hate them people
mostly people hate them did you feel the
pressure to like do something
celebrity worthy oh my gosh well so ours
was very
last minute like to the point of we went
and got our ultrasound
i told my husband we're not going to
look because they're going to give us an
envelope
and we're going to do it with our family
and friends tomorrow and we get the
envelope and he said to me lindsay there
is no way in heck i'm waiting till
tomorrow
if the family wants to come tonight to
the house we'll do it if not i'm opening
this envelope i was like okay so i'm
texting my family like get to the house
now sam is going to open this thing
so we did it like super last minute i'm
glad we did
but it was interesting because it was in
the middle of quarantine i mean my
gender reveal was in may i think
yeah so right even if we wanted to do
something hollywood worthy it wouldn't
have worked out so i'm kind of glad that
i didn't have to that was like my excuse
i'm like oh yeah sorry it's quarantined
i can't do it
did you feel pressure yeah i mean not
pressure but we just
wanted it to be a big thing because this
was just a huge i mean
carson wanted a son so bad so it was
like it was a big deal for us and we
have a big family so we were like let's
just everybody get cannons
and we'll just make a big thing about it
yeah and carson was a little bit the
same way like he could not
wait to open it and i was like don't you
dare pop one of those cannons i will
literally kill you
did you know no we had no idea but when
we picked up the box because they had
surprises right they like fill the
cannons with the confetti
so we grabbed the box and at the bottom
of the box was a little pink confetti
and so and so both cars tonight when we
went to bed we were like okay it'll be
fine like we have a girl
that's so fun like you thought it was we
thought it was a girl
that's actually completely like
completely and so carson was trying to
wrap his head around he's like okay i'm
gonna
it's gonna be fine and so when everybody
popped those cannons it was just like
a complete surprise like that's
completely shocked so
it was really really funny do you think
they do that i don't know
they should because that's fun what the
heck i know i know it's really
good really really good how has it been
getting the nurseries ready
oh the fact has been so much fun i
literally just walked into her nursery
and saw it for the first time and it is
so cute
both of our nurseries are done and we
have the same designer do both of our
homes and our nurseries and they're like
yep
the freaking best that was the thing i
was looking forward to most was the
nursery
and i have to say after they installed
everything
and sam and i go into that room and see
that we have a crib in our house it was
like
the weirdest feeling and coolest feeling
ever we're like oh my god it's real
like this is happening i know real yeah
baby's room
it's just it's so cool and surreal
[Music]
welcome back to our positively dope 80s
night
watching dancing with the stars from
home are you judgy
are you like planning your neck you are
yes okay tell me about that well
i just i don't know i i won't say judge
you like in a bad way but i'm literally
watching like i want to critique it and
kind of like
trying to pick things apart and thinking
about it like oh that would have been
better if they did this or oh that was
such a good choice or
and then it's also different because
you'll hear the judge's comments and i
immediately like
put myself in their shoes because
there's so many times the judges say
things and as a pro you're just like
either like okay like i know his frame
was bad we've been working on it all
week
and it's funny because i get invested in
it but then at the same time like i'm
not stressed about anything
i'm not like worried about my score
it's just like i watch it subjectively
and i know obviously i'm like
okay i would i agree with that or that
was so dumb but then you feel
so weird like watching the commercial
breaks because usually like commercial
breaks were like in the back like
stressing
like energy and i'm literally eating
food i'm like wow this looks a lot
different than last year it's completely
different it's so crazy i kind of
i'm not i don't feel like i'm as
invested watching it like i'm kind of
just like
enjoying just just watching it as an
audience member like i'm not really
picking it apart which is weird because
i feel like i would have been
yeah but i did some kind of like oh this
is so nice i don't have to worry about
anything
[Music]
[Applause]
and so you guys are fully in you're back
next season like have these babies yeah
i'm like i'm so happy for you but like
we need you back in the ballroom oh i
it feels good to film this that's for
sure yes i
have every intention of coming back next
season like obviously i can't guarantee
anything because who knows how my
how things will go but like yeah
everything i want to come back i have
every intention of coming back
and yes and i feel like we have good
timing where we'll have at least like
five six months to like get back into
that mindset so
now peta has she been giving you advice
not for
me really i haven't talked to her lately
but she's awesome just
like supporting i know i i talked when i
first got pregnant and she was like
just enjoy every minute of it like this
is the biggest blessing in your life and
just been
really encouraging and positive yeah
same with me i think and two from the
beginning she's always just said like
you're gonna have a lot of people
telling you what to do or how to do
things but just listen to you and say
like you and sam are the end-all be-all
you guys decide on your own which i
really appreciate because it's true a
lot of people give
advice which is great but at the end of
the day like every baby's different
every mom is different so you kind of
just have to figure it out on your own
so i'm grateful that
she's been so supportive in that way and
not tried to be like you have to do this
or anything i'm definitely going to call
her though on how she got back her body
yes we want i have a surprise for you i
want to grab my phone
it's on my phone okay i'm going back on
my spot
okay let me pull it up
i love the sounds that sound familiar
that is literally me
every moment of the day so i'm glad i'm
not hey youtube beautiful women i just
wanted to send you some big big love
and said i'm so excited you guys are
sharing this time of pregnancy with each
other
uh but i did i just wanted to say one
thing real quick
is that it's a bit rude honestly with
how good you both look pregnant
it's bit rude it's you've set the bar
just a smidge high i think for the rest
of us when that time comes
but that aside you are freaking glowing
you look beautiful
pregnancy looks good on you i can only
imagine that motherhood is going to be
even better
and i already know being the humans that
you are you're going to be the most
incredible mothers so congratulations
best of luck
i cannot wait to squeeze you guys uh and
i cannot wait to meet the new members of
your family
lindsay and whitney my two gorgeous
utah girls oh i miss you
i miss you out here um your energy
and your talent and your beauty is so
missed this season on the show
um but i think both of you have had some
pretty epic and incredible moments in
life and in your career
but i have a feeling that this is gonna
be the biggest and most special one yet
i am so proud of you i cannot wait to
see
both of you become the most beautiful
mothers i can't believe you guys are
gonna have kids
um but i'm just so excited i can't wait
to snuggle the babies
oh my goodness and i cannot wait
to see what little dancers the two of
you make
love you guys so much miss you
we're lens we miss you in the ballroom
and congratulations on the babies
we're so excited that we're now auntie
and uncle and we can't wait to see you
and meet your baby soon love you
maybe they can dance together maybe
maybe hi lindsay hi whitney
hey you guys we're so excited for you to
experience this little box oh my god
goodness we're so excited for you both
to be new moms it honestly
is the greatest joy in the whole wide
world there's no
better greater love than this it's true
yes
congrats and best of luck that's the
vlog
i will need it yeah oh my god that was
the sweetest thing i
almost i was tearing up i was like
tearing up a little bit
i was so sweet oh my gosh
i think for you so i love that that's
like honestly
the biggest and kind of been like the
hardest thing is
i like miss our friends so much and it
blows i mean it's been hard because we
haven't seen them i mean the last time i
saw them was when we all got sent home
from the dance and the stars tour
but having like gosh i'm so grateful for
face time and a lot like
just everything that keeps us connected
because they have been
so supportive like genuinely every
single pro on the show i've
kept in contact with and they've reached
out and it just means
so much because those are the people
that i want my baby to like i want them
to like love my baby and i know they
will i can't wait for it
hold on so that was so sweet well you
know you're like very disconnected
because you're not only you're pregnant
not on the show but with covid
it's like there isn't like you didn't
take a trip to go sit in the ballroom
you know which we would have done for
sure really hard because i just took a
trip
it to huntington like two weeks ago and
i was gonna try and see everybody and
they're like no we can't even like
family is like not even
allowed in there like it's so crazy so
it was just really sad
okay well e.t has a little present for
you oh that's so
nice this is wonderful the best day ever
okay and gifts
oh my gosh oh
i definitely think this is going to have
to be the coming from home from the
hospital outfit like
without a doubt i love it
okay i know isn't it crazy to think
you're gonna have a little little one
like that i'm sure everyone's giving you
presents so you're like oh my god my
kid's gonna be safe i love it how is it
that like a little thing that fits in
this
is right here like literally ready to
get in the outwards that is so bizarre
oh my goodness tiny so cute i love that
you guys
i know that's awesome nice thank you